hi my name is Daniel Pham and welcome to
this week in Android development for
Monday January 13 2014 over the past few
weeks we've been hard at work making
Android better faster and stronger that
doesn't mean we weren't in the studio
producing episodes of your favorite
content though so make sure you check
out Android design and actions recap of
all their shows in 2013 we also had
nozzle and Paul saxman explain what
context is and why it matters are an
episode of uxd Todd continues his
infiltration with less than 2.2 in a
series on play games for iOS and finally
Dan lavelle introduced us all to a new
series we're calling play bytes not to
be forgotten our team members in Japan
and Korea released a few dev and design
bites as well including actionbarcompat
and chromium webview in both Japanese
and Korean we've got a ton of new
content coming out the next few weeks so
make sure you subscribe to our channel
that's all for this week in Android
development I'm Daniel Pham it's in the
palm of your hand now baby it's a yes or
a No No maybe